[Music]
javascript is a single-threaded
programming language yet everything we
do on the web tends to be blocking or
time-consuming which means that
asynchronous programming is an essential
skill for any JavaScript developer
today's video will focus primarily on
the amazing syntactic sugar provided by
async await but before we can get there
we really need to understand things from
the ground up starting with the browser
or nodejs event loop callbacks promises
and then finally async await and we're
going to do this without making a single
joke about a sink or a wave if you're
new here like and subscribe and we'll be
giving away another one of a kind
t-shirt with this video all you have to
do is leave a comment below and we'll
pick a random winner next week in order
to understand anything async you really
need to first understand the event loop
this is ace I hope that clears up any
questions you have I'm going to give you
the general overview but I highly
recommend you watch this talk from Jake
Archibald which is the best explanation
of the event loop that I've ever seen
then after you're done watching that
talk you should check out Stephen
fluence demos with angular Channel which
just released a video about callbacks
which are one of the things that happen
within the event loop so what is the
event loop and what does it have to do
with async away both the browser and
nodejs are always running a single
threaded event loop to run your code on
the first go around it will run all of
your synchronous code but it might also
queue up asynchronous events to be
called back later you say here's a
function that I need to run but first I
need to go get some data from the
network the event loop says okay I'll
keep doing my thing while you do your
thing in a separate thread pool then at
some point in the future get data will
finish and let the event loop know that
it's ready to be called back now this is
where things get interesting if it's a
macro task like a set timeout or set
interval it will be executed on the next
event loop but if it's a micro task like
a fulfilled promise then it will be
called back before the start of the next
event loop let's look at the
implications of this by writing some
actual code first we will write a
console log which is synchronous then
we'll throw in a set timeout but give it
a time delay of zero milliseconds then
we'll have a promise that resolves right
away and lastly we will add another
console log for one more synchronous
line of code so nothing here has any
actual time delay so intuitively I would
think that
each line of code would be executed one
by one but that's not how things work in
the event loop if we execute this code
you can see that first line gets logged
up right away because it's running on
the main thread then if we run the
second line it's being queued for a
future task then the promise is being
cued to run in the micro task queue
immediately after this current task and
finally the last console log gets
executed right away so even though the
set timeout call back was queued up
before the promise the promise still
gets executed first because of the
priority of the micro task queue so now
that you know how the event loop works
we can start looking at promises first
I'll show you how a promise based API
might be consumed and then we'll look at
how we actually create our own promises
from scratch so fetch is a browser-based
API but it's also available on node via
the node fetch library and it allows us
to hit an HTTP endpoint and have the
response returned to us as a promise of
the response fetching data from a remote
server is always going to be a sync so
we can queue up the promise then provide
it with a callback to map it to JSON the
great thing about promises is that we
can chain them together mapping to JSON
is also a promise so we can return that
promise from the original then callback
and then in the next one we'll have the
actual user data as a plain JavaScript
object if we go ahead and run this code
you'll see it runs our console log first
and then it retrieves the data from the
API and console logs that afterwards the
great thing about promises is that you
can catch all errors in the chain with a
single function we can do this by adding
catch to the bottom of our promise chain
and it will handle errors that happen
anywhere within our asynchronous code if
this code were callback based we'd have
to have a separate error handler for
every single one of the asynchronous
operations so if an error is thrown
anywhere in our code it's going to
bypass all of the future then callbacks
and go straight to the catch callback
when you start creating promises that's
when you're more likely to screw things
up first I'm setting up a log function
so I can show you the elapsed time
between each line of code up a while
loop that loops a billion times
arbitrarily if we run this on the main
thread it's going to block all of their
code from executing until the billion
loops are done so we'll do one console
log run our while loop and then do
another console log after that and you
can see it takes about seven
milliseconds to finish the while loop
our script is essentially frozen until
that while loop is complete so let's go
ahead and wrap this code in a promise so
we can get it off the main thread and
execute it as a micro task this is one
tricky little way you might screw things
up so we create a new promise we add our
code inside that promise and then we
have it resolved to that value when done
so you might think that because we're
wrapping this in a promise that we're
going to execute this off the main
thread but the actual creation of the
promise and that big while loop is still
happening on the main thread it's only
the resolving of the value that happens
as a micro task
so the first synchronous line gets
logged right away and the second one
should too but there's still a 700
millisecond delay because that while
loop is still blocking on the main
thread so to ensure that all of our
synchronous code runs as fast as
possible we'll refactor our code once
again to say promise resolve then we'll
run the while loop inside of that result
promises callback by putting this code
inside of a resolved promise we can be
guaranteed that it will be executed
after all the synchronous code in the
current macro task has completed if we
go ahead and run our script again you
can see we get our two console logs
right away and then finally the promise
resolves after 700 milliseconds so now
that you know all that stuff you should
be in the clear to use async await
responsibly we already know that
promises are a huge improvement over
callbacks but promises can still be
really hard to read and follow
especially when you have a long chain of
multiple asynchronous events async await
really just boils down to syntactic
sugar to make your asynchronous code
read like synchronous code first let's
look at the async part of the equation
and see what that does so here we have a
regular function that does nothing and
if we put the async keyword in front of
it we have a function that returns a
promise of nothing so whatever gets
returned inside this function will be a
promise of that value I'm going to reuse
this get fruit function throughout the
lesson just to simulate what a promise
based API looks like in this case the
user can pass in the name of a fruit and
then the function will resolve to the
value of the fruit emoji from this
object and just to make this a little
more clear if we didn't use the async
keyword we could write this function by
just returning a promise that resolves
to this value so when you use the async
keyword the matte
that happens is that it takes the return
value and automatically resolves it as a
promise but that's not everything that
it does it also sets up a context for
you to use the await keyword the real
power of an async function comes when
you combine it with the away keyword to
pause the execution of the function now
I'm going to write a second async
function called make smoothie what we
need to do is get multiple fruits and
then combine them together as a single
value instead of chaining together a
bunch of then callbacks we can just have
a promise resolve to the value of a
variable a weight is like saying pause
the execution of this function until the
get fruit promise results to a value at
which point we can use it as the
variable a and then we'll move on to the
next line of code after we get a
pineapple we can then get a strawberry
and then we'll turn them together as an
array one of the most annoying things
with promises is that it's kind of
difficult to share result values between
multiple steps in the promise chain but
async/await solves this problem really
nicely the code on the right is what
this would look like if we wrote it with
just regular promises and as you can see
there's a lot more code and a lot more
complexity there now if you're already a
JavaScript expert then I'm kind of
trolling you because you know that the
code on the left is making the single
biggest mistake that people make when
using async await and that is failing to
run the code concurrently if we go back
to the code on the left you can see that
we're waiting for a pineapple to resolve
and then we're getting a strawberry
afterwards but we could get both of
these things at the same time you really
only need to await one thing after the
other if the second value is dependent
on the first value for example if you
need to get a user ID before you can
then retrieve some data from the
database let's imagine we're making
these calls from a remote API and
there's about a second of latency if we
run this code again with a delay you can
see it takes a full second to get the
first fruit and then a full second to
get the second fruit but the whole point
of the event loop is to avoid blocking
code like this so we know that an async
function always returns a promise so
instead of doing one after the other we
can add both of our promises to promise
all this will tell all the promises in
the array to run concurrently and then
have the resolved values be at that
index in the array so this is something
that you should always be thinking about
when working with async functions you
don't want to accidentally pause
function unnecessarily so instead of
awaiting a whole bunch of individual
promises you might want to add all your
promises to an array and then await that
promise all call and as you can see here
we've doubled the speed of the original
function another nice benefit of async
await is error handling instead of
chaining a catch callback to our promise
chain we can just wrap our code in a
try-catch block this offers much better
flexibility when handling errors that
might occur across multiple promises if
we take our code from the last example
and throw an error in the middle of it
we can then catch that error down here
in the catch block the first thing we'll
probably want to do here is console.log
the error and then we can either catch
the error and throw another error or we
can catch the error and return a value
your decision here will dictate the
control flow for the consumer of this
promise if you return a value it's
basically like ignoring the error and
then providing some replacement value so
the consumer the promise won't get an
error but instead they'll get the result
value inside of the then callback in
contrast if we throw an error inside of
our catch block it will break the
consumers promise chain and be handled
by their catch callback now I want to
show you a couple of tricks to make your
code as sweet as possible let's imagine
we have a string of IDs and then we want
to retrieve all these ideas from the
database we can use a ray map to convert
them to an array of promises and then
resolve them all concurrently using
promise doll that looks great but you
need to be careful when using
async/await
in a map or for each loop because it
won't actually pause the function in
this context so normally we would expect
this loop to stop if we do a wait get
fruit but that's actually not what
happens in this case instead it will run
all these promises concurrently so that
might not be the behavior that you're
expecting if you want to run a loop and
have every iteration in that loop a way
to promise you need to use a traditional
for loop so you can write async
functions and then write a for loop
inside that function and then use the
await keyword inside the loop when you
write your code like this it will pause
each step of a loop until that promise
is resolved but more often than not
you'll probably want to run everything
concurrently and a cool thing you can do
is use the await keyword directly in a
for loop if you have a promise that you
know results to an array you can
actually just use the await keyword
directly in your loop so you can say for
await in your code what
we'll await the array of items to
resolve and then loop over them
immediately after and as you can
probably imagine you can also use the
await keyword in your conditionals on
the left side of the conditional we can
await the result value from a promise
and then we can see if it's equal to
some other value so that gives you a
super concise way to write conditional
expressions when working with promises
hopefully that gives you some ideas on
what you can do with async await in ES 7
or typescript it is truly one of the
sweetest things to ever happen to
JavaScript if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and make sure
to join the live stream next week for
the t-shirt giveaway and if you want to
take your development to the next level
consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase comm you'll get access
to all kinds of advanced content
designed to help you build and ship your
app faster thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you soon